foreign
hi Savannah welcome to the Ramsey Show
how are you
and we deserve what's up
um we are homeowners and our property
taxes and car insurance rates in Florida
went up like crazy this past year we are
under on a lot of our bills and we've
been trying to make it work with our
savings our savings are running out in
the next few months and we're trying to
decide if we should sell our home
because we have a lot of equity in the
home or if we should accept a ten
thousand dollar gift from a family
member to help us be able to stay in the
home a little longer
okay so Savannah how much how much is
your home worth
um a realtor came and they said our home
was worth about four hundred thousand
and how much do you owe on it
um I believe uh we got it two years ago
it was 251.
um I'm sorry I'm blanking how much we
owe on it still
um they said we'd walk away with
um a hundred and thirty thousand roughly
um if we got for what it was worth
and how much do you owe in your car
um our cars are a big issue we pay
um all our debt we owe about 25
um for our debt
what what do you owe on your car
um my car is I believe 16 000 and my
husband's is 5 000.
what's your household income
um we bring home about 3 900 a month
okay what are you gonna do when the ten
thousand dollar gift Runs Out
what what we should do I wanted to make
the right choice
well the fact that the 10 000 gift is a
is a it's just Financial denial
I mean you're just kicking the can down
the road you still haven't dealt with a
problem
the problem is your budget's upside down
okay right that's kind of what you were
already thinking yeah you were already
thinking that so what's your household
income again
3 900.
a month
um oh I'm sorry a month
four thousand dollars a month how much
is your house payment
um it went up to 1700 a month uh this
time yeah I saw your house
okay you can't afford the house and it
wasn't the insurance you couldn't afford
it before
and you may need to sell the 16 000 car
too
okay y'all are swimming in stress aren't
you
yes we are this is not fun are y'all
fighting
no we're we're we're handling it pretty
well we're trying to trust the Lord
um and decide what to do
oh yeah
but I feel like we've been doing okay
I'm kidding with you all right so how
long you guys been married how long
you've been married
three years okay and you've been
collecting crap the whole time you got
married now you got a big old pile of
crap and a big old pile of debt so let's
get rid of a bunch of crap and get your
life back
okay sell the 16 000 car sell the house
and get your life back I want you to
like your life in each other again yeah
and there's a part of trusting the Lord
absolutely we're people of Faith but
there's also that Savannah you guys have
to do you you guys have to make
decisions hard decisions and you have to
put action towards things that are
needed right do you get that too like if
I weigh 300 pounds and I want to lose
weight I can't just trust the Lord I
have to back off the donuts
right there's both things right and that
that's the thing and that that's like
Dave's example because Dave's addicted
to Donuts so uh although I have I'm
donut free for gosh about almost three
years now I'm donut-free so you bring
Donut Star house pretty good I'm gonna
get my little donut coin soon oh my gosh
but um yeah
um but yeah Savannah I mean and I think
for you guys honestly
um if you stay on the line Austin's
gonna pick up because I want you guys
you and your husband you've been married
three years to go through Financial
Peace University this is nine lessons on
exactly step by step what to do with
your money because you guys are just
kind of
you're just you're just normal I mean
really is what it comes down to you're
like you have a great house you have
great cars and you think oh God everyone
else seems to be getting ahead and doing
well and here I am and there's there's a
lot of stress to this life that looks
like it should be okay and it's not and
I don't know what we're doing wrong and
so having a very methodical plan where
you guys are on the same page and you
know what's going on and you actually
have a plan that you're working towards
and that's probably going to mean
selling the house
um that's going to mean selling the car
I've just been backing off on some stuff
because yeah I mean you guys are you
know I mean after taxes you're probably
bringing home 40K
um so that's what you have to work with
and there's a lot of deck here compared
to that income and so it's probably does
feel very overwhelming but it's possible
to to change all of this but it's going
to require a lot of sacrifice and
diligence on you guys on your end and
you can do that if you'll take a machete
to some of this junk in your life you'll
um you'll get a life back because right
now you don't even realize how how hard
it is to breathe yeah because you're
just you're concentrating and you're
being sweet and honestly you called with
the exact right question and you already
knew the answer to it that the ten
thousand dollars just kicks the can down
the road it's you're living in an
unsustainable set of mathematics
and the mathematics are kicking your
butt and you you already knew that so
you're you're on top of it you're gonna
you got the stuff to win Rachel's right
we'll get you signed up for Financial
Peace University you know her case is
almost like a stereotypical case study
thing Larry Burkett used to say we
spend the first seven years of our
marriage trying to attain the same
standard of living as our parents
but it took them 35 or 40 years to get
there yeah and we do it in four or five
years of marriage they've been married
three years four years and they just
been get a house get cars get a house
get cars get ready baby and you just
gather and then you all of a sudden you
look up and you go oh crap I can't
breathe oh I'm gonna kill you the
stressor I'm gonna kill my spouse my
stresses level is so high and so you
know and and but that's the the problem
is the stupid banks will loan you so
much money that they put you in
bankruptcy
because they don't have an off button
they'll just loan you money you know you
can go get a credit card you can go on a
trip you can't afford you can go you go
down there and get a car and I'm like
you know I was sitting with a young
couple when I first started doing
coaching many years ago
their take-home pay was 2 600 bucks and
the guy had a 1200 car payment
which was a that's insane for it now
saying 30 years ago that was yeah that
would be like having a 3 000 or 2500 car
payment now right but he you know 2600
our take-home pay 1200 car payment yeah
and he's like we're having trouble
paying for our kids food and I'm like
well no kidding I said you need to sell
a stupid car man and he's like no
um I can't sell the car I said yes you
can there's no God gave us that currency
God did not give you that car
he goes how you know I said because the
scripture is real clear the blessings of
the Lord have no sorrow added to them
and this has got sorrow written all over
it Bubba and he goes well even the
finance manager said it was a miracle
I bet it was a dad come miracle that
some Bank approved your crazy butt
little purchase but they will they will
loan you so much that even the finance
manager thinks it's a miracle can't
believe it went through must be the Lord
oh I made another
Saleh thank you Lord oh my gosh guy and
God's up there going I got nothing to do
with this don't blame this on me
don't put my name there
oh hey the banks will loan you so much
they just you know and you know there's
actually people out there walking around
that still think that if the bank will
loan it to you it means you can afford
it it's the same people that thinks if
you have checks left in your checkbook
there must be money in the account
it's the same people
well because you can afford the payment
you know what I mean like that's that's
the mindset I can afford the the living
situation that we're in because we're
not behind on payments and all of it
right so you're just staying right
afloat and that's where risk and life
and job loss and sickness all that never
comes into play but when it does then
that's your wake-up call